[موسيقى]
راهنت على مساله بعث الحاله القوميه
القوميه الروسيه والاعتماد عليها حتى
الموجات صحيح انهم اعلنوا الجهات يعني
وصدرت فتوى من الشيشان وانما يجب بعض
المفتين داخل الجمهوريه الاسلاميه انما
يجري هو جهات في سبيل الله لحمايه صالح
روسيا
[موسيقى]
لا مشكله لدى هذه التنظيمات ان تقاتل في
صف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او الغرب
طالما ان ذلك سوف ينهك ينهك الروس او ينهك
الغرب ذاته هم ينظرون الى هذه الحرب انها
سوف تنهك الطرفين ثم تعطيهم فرصه مثاليه
للتدريب وللتسلح وللبقاء وللوجود وللقتال
[موسيقى]
ايران في المعادله يعني ايران موجوده في
المعادله نحن نعلم ان قياده التنظيم
القاعده الرئيسيه الان سواء سيف العدل
وكان من قبل محمد المصري وغيره من قراءه
التنظيم موجودين في طهران يعني
ويعني
ويتمتعون بحمايه كبيره جدا من الدوله
الايرانيه منذ فتره طويله وفق اتفاقيه
معروفه في وساق ابو ثبات والموضوع هذا طرق
بحثا بشكل كبير جدا اذا لا مشكله وايران
هي الداعم ولديها دعم مؤسف وكبير جدا جدا
للروس في هذه الحرب اذن لا مشكله لدى
التنظيم القاعده ولا لدي ايران في التعاون
ونقل المقاتلين الى الجبهه الى الجبهه
الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]